so Amber heard's attorney objected to
his own question I gotta see this you
were not informed as to what caused
damage to Mr Depp's hand finger on
marches objection hearsay his
objectively hearsay you're asking what
they were told sustain the objection
next question you didn't know what could
cause damage to Mr def's Hand while you
were there on March 8th that's an
ambiguous question you can know
something by being told something or
just viewing it firsthand Dr Kepler told
me he sustained an injury on one of his
rejection here's hearsay I mean you
asked the question okay oh boy the
problem here is that he asked an
ambiguous question that elicited a
hearsay response I mean it's complicated
it might not be hearsay that's a
different issue and it's not that he
objected to his own question it's that
he objected to the testimony what he
should have done is made a motion to the
court to strike the answer as hearsay
but effectively the judge is saying you
asked the question it might not be
hearsay so you can live with the answer
and everyone is exasperated here it's
not the finest lawyering I've ever seen
but being a trial lawyer is hard you
only have a split second and this is a
totally normal thing that happens all
the time albeit phrased in an
unfortunate way that kind of makes this
lawyer look bad